Peter it's lovely to see here at
collector mania today what are you
surprised that people don't ask you
about your time has been on the show the
one thing that does surprise me is they
never ask about the technical abilities
of the time because people make jokes
about you know the Robley sets and all
the rest of it not very wide angle shots
and people running up down the same
corridor slightly different camera
angles and so on but I mean the
technical ability of the time was you
know doctor who was at the cutting edge
of it really and it was money more than
anything else that stopped it being
clever I thought to be honest the doctor
who would have died when Star Trek
started because suddenly there was a
show which was a long similar lines at
least it was sci-fi and everything that
had a huge amount of money pumped into
it and doctor who was being made for
threatens and somehow it survived and I
reckon it was the quality of the writing
and possibly one could even say was it
was the quality of Bill Hartnell's
acting you know he created something
which really has this on Garrety now
when you look back and you think gosh I
was with the first incarnation of the
doctor what does it meet you feel I'm
chuffed immense I mean it's great and
for me he is the doctor he always it'll
never be anyone else who can usurp him
from that he created it and so every
doctor that's come after doesn't matter
how good they are as actors and they've
been some cracking actors in there
they're not the doctor not for me but no
it's yeah it's I'm very proud of the
fact that I was in it it's quite
interesting in I did 46 episodes in
total counting the one when I wasn't
playing Stephen miles play Morton dill
that was in a year and Colin Baker was
the doctor for three years he did 29
episodes I mean the difference is that
when we did it was very much like weekly
rep you know we did a different show
each week you went in started rehearsing
on that on the Monday you did the show
recorded on the Friday as if it was a
live thing and it was you know it was a
bit of a sausage factory
what did you enjoy most about playing
see even though I J of characters I was
allowed to play we did the historical
stories I thought were great
unfortunately they don't really exist
the massacre doesn't exist the
mythmakers doesn't exist the savages
doesn't really exist though that was
more sci-fi than historical so it's
disappointing in that respect the time
medal is the only one that has a
historical edge that does survive but
that was a real mix of time travel plus
the the history of the the Saxon times
in Britain so see they were always the
interesting ones for me I didn't like
working with the Daleks and the
Chumley's and all that I didn't find
them interesting and they're certainly
not scary when you're working with them
in the scene do you know were you scared
of the Daleks no but I never say that to
kids always oh yeah of course there's
going to be a show about the making or
the beginnings of doctor who isn't on
the BBC very shortly a venture in space
and time cancer is a non-speaking part
in that but I I'm not involved in it but
I like to think I helped towards the
finished script because I had a nice
evening with Mark Gatiss and a few
anecdotal things I'll be interested to
see if they're in the in the film I met
I've never met David Bradley before
today I think he's brilliant casting for
absolutely brilliant casting and I know
that Anika wills has seen it and she
says you actually watch it mrs. bill
Hartnell's fantastic performance he's
not trying to do an impression he's or
an impersonation I should say it's an
impression it's fantastic what did I
like about the man behind the doctor III
well I admired bill very much as an
actor before I joined I mean he made 70
films and one forgets like you know
prolific film actor and it was great to
walk into the rehearsal room on the
first episode that I did to see Bill
Hartnell standing there I was very
impressed I really was impressed the
nice thing about doing the show was it
was at the time when better actors were
being engaged
to play the other parts and it could
that grew because prior to that to a
certain extent actors tend to frown a
little bit at television because there
wasn't a lot of television worked for
actors mostly they would carry on
working on the stage so the stage was
the thing so to work on television was
young people put down their noses a bit
at it so as great actors started to come
into the serial that was wonderful as
well I mean I felt quite humble at times
I was a regular in the serial but you've
got people like Andre Morrell coming in
max Adrian great actors we've got our
next doctor already lined up everywhere
he's going to be Peter Capaldi what do
you think Peter will bring to the role
of the doctor I think he's a great
brother casting funnily enough you know
he's older now I think the bill Hartnell
was when he played the doctor originally
don't think he looks at mine I think he
can bring a lot to it I don't think
you'll swear much I hope not if I'm
certainly way but I like his acting I
like his style I'm sure he'll be very
good but who knows what the scripts are
like I mean that the scripturally
determine how it's going to be and what
Peter brings to it will be between him
and the producers and what he's allowed
to get away with and I mean who knows I
don't know how much actors are allowed
to dictate what happens so you know the
production will be what it is his
performance will be what it is I'm
looking forward to it because I think
it'll be very good and if you were asked
to return to the TARDIS at any point or
return to the universe as any character
would you like to do that and who would
you like to return I would leap at it I
wouldn't care as I would love a part in
it I would be delighted to play don't
even want a leading part just give me a
partner I'd be very very happy we'd love
to see you in it because
thanks so much for talking to us today
you're welcome
you